okay good morning everyone so my name is
the in Stokes race I'm sorry for the
little arc angle of people who are
behind this pillar who I can't see cuz I
can tell there's about half a dozen of
you there but hopefully you can see the
screen that I'm presenting on and I'm
gonna take about the next 30 minutes
actually probably a little bit less cuz
I'd love to have a some time for some
Q&A questions people have about anaconda
and open data science at the end that's
gonna get us on on time for our 10:30
morning coffee break so I'm a
computational scientist to continuum to
set the scene just a little bit give you
a bit of my background to understand
where I'm coming from and in fact we're
really the majority of people doing
engineering work at continuum come from
my email signature still says that I'm a
computational scientist my business card
says that I'm a data scientist my email
signature goes out to more people like
you my business card goes out to people
we're trying to pay us money and data
scientist is like the thing they want to
see in a business card for the person
they talk to you
my background is electrical engineer as
an undergraduate Canadian are there any
other Canadians here I've met one or two
know other Canadians but anyway so I did
large-scale data processing signal
processing at the end of my
undergraduate degree carried that into
large statistical models for speech
recognition for a master's degree and
then I worked at a tech startup in the
UK for a couple years where we did
government data processing systems for
processing electronic records for tax
filing and so it was like kind of one of
the biggest ever attempts to put these
things online and of course everybody
files their taxes in the same kind of
like six-hour window and again was like
problems in large-scale data processing
and then I started a PhD where I really
learned the definition of big where I
was working on one of the certain
experiments
where I was on the computing team for
the LHCb experiment one of the four
detectors at CERN the baby experiment
with only 300 physicists and you know as
opposed to 2,000 like the other three
but this is for an experiment and a
group of people who are gonna be working
together for most of their professional
lives it's a very tight community they
were at the experiments last for decades
the collaborations are massive and are
tightly knit and so we are creating
software infrastructure for running on
over a quarter million machines that
would be running for more than a decade
so stuff that I wrote like in 2003 2004
parts of it are still in the computing
infrastructure that's deployed and a
globally distributed computing
infrastructure and it's cranking through
petabytes of data every year so that's
like big scale distributed processing
and that's where I learned Python that
computing team was committed to Python
CERN is heavily invested in Python
Python is amazing I love it and the
people at continuum have been using
Python for a long time since well before
continuum came into existence and we're
in this world today where a lot of
people are excited about what you can do
with computers and data and software and
algorithms and anaconda is our continuum
sort of collective gift to the world
it's free for everyone it's free for any
use it's free for ever since we say
about the Anaconda distribution how many
people here are using anaconda today
great so most people some people aren't
I love to hear stories from people who
aren't using anaconda so we love to
understand like what are the situations
that make anaconda like not the right
answer for you so you're using it you've
got a bit of a picture of what's there
in anaconda we have we heard yesterday
some statistics on Windows Python
downloads so as you all are familiar you
go to Python Software Foundation
download Python from Python org and you
get like this depending on what it is
exactly 25 to 35 Meg download with a
Python standard library now just to see
if people are awake and listening
they're not doing email or text messages
too much approximately how many Python
package
are in the Python standard library does
anybody know have you ever wondered so
if you go to a doc stop Python org and
click on that like modules link how many
things are listed with that no in the
standard library that you get when you
install pythons Python from python.org
so the answer is about 300 sorry about
300 they're round figures okay notice
about 300 that's ya round again round
figures it's about 300 packages in there
Python standard library Python standard
library is amazing for those of us
who've been doing stuff for a long time
we have to or work in other domains
MATLAB or Java or wherever else
every time you move to like a new job or
new computer you get like the built-in
stuff and all the extra bits you've got
to go and download and get them from a
million different places the standard
library is like the one of the crown
jewels of Python Python ecosystem
anaconda takes that idea and extends it
for data science and so it takes things
which goes beyond Python so the Anaconda
distribution although it's Python
centric it's not Python exclusive the
anaconda distribution packs in over 200
additional tools and libraries for data
science all open source libraries their
pre compiled and optimized for Windows
Mac and Linux and we do quarterly
releases of those things if you don't
want to be bothered with like doing
rolling updates or selectively this
package that package this version that
version you can just you know pull down
the latest version every time we release
a new version every every three months
approximately and you get the whole
thing at all and it all just works
before anaconda there was then thought
Python distribution which got to be like
part of the way there but has had some
limits in terms of how you could extend
it or how you could actually use it how
and interacted with your system now one
of the key things that anaconda enables
is besides an ease of use starting point
for open data science it also gives you
the ability to work with other people
and to work with other computing systems
so how many people in this room are
running Linux on their laptops right now
like not in a VM that's
what they've got installed one person
two people one and a half's this guy
priors in a VM he probably use it at the
moment or in a partition okay dual boot
right and how many people in this in
this room on a daily basis are executing
stuff on a UNIX based server Oh actually
it's a smaller number than I expected I
suspect like everybody put their hands
up
so my operational reality is I use my
Mac laptop day in day out and I do like
tons of computing on it and like I love
these packed out like Cadillac Mac's
with you know terabyte drives and
everything it's awesome but I also do a
heck of a lot of computing on UNIX based
clusters and servers and the reality is
for us is people who are interested in
scientific computing in large-scale
Canoe we've got a transition from our
laptops to bigger systems at some point
anaconda makes it really easy to do that
because you can have an account like
it's this first level you have anaconda
on your laptop you can have an account
on your servers you've got that same
starting point additionally you're
working with other people who are more
like on the business end and like Excel
is their world and Windows is their
world they can have anaconda there too
and so even if they're just like
dabbling into some of this stuff they
can get it on the window spaces so this
is stuff you probably already know but
the idea is is that we we allow people
to like transition between those
different environments the business
oriented Windows environment the more
data science like Mac environment and
then the more computational UNIX type
setups okay so dive an addict on
immortal today I'm gonna talk and I've
only begun to talk from another 15
minutes my goal and then have some
conversation about anaconda QA about
conda anaconda the Anaconda ecosystem I
want to give you a picture of the
anaconda distribution so you had a clear
mental model of what you what you get in
it
so you're not just like yeah I love it
and then you talk to somebody else who's
like I don't know I'm just gonna like
home brew brew install Python or I'm
gonna like yum install numpy right and
and you like don't have good answers
you're like that seems like a bad idea
but you don't know what to say right my
goal is to give you some ammunition so
you can help spread the Anaconda love
and so that you can help tamp down on
the foot because there's like anaconda
Fudd out there for people who think like
oh my gosh it's gonna like ruin my life
create all sorts of problems means that
kind of thing I also want to show off a
little bit of the bigger like community
around anaconda so look at anaconda
cloud how many people here have heard of
anaconda cloud before if I say that
okay so anaconda cloud we're gonna look
at that a little bit we're gonna look at
what it gives you and what what
opportunities exists there and then a
few other pieces Conda Forge how many
people here have heard of Conda Forge
before small numbers okay so you'll be
excited to hear about Conda Forge and
then finally just so that people don't
think yeah but like people got to pay
that guy's salary and I didn't hear him
say anything about what they sells
there's got to be small print somewhere
at the very end I'm gonna just take a
couple minutes only for the sake of like
clarifying for all of you like what is
it the continuum does commercially how
is it that we actually like make money
when are we gonna ask you for like a
credit card number or for dollar bills
something like that so I'll be the dick
at the very end just to set some context
for continuum as a company but mostly
this is focused on the open source stuff
the free stuff in the Anaconda ecosystem
alright so MATLAB Python r MATLAB and
Jupiters what's the quickest way to get
these three pieces all working together
so I'm gonna like kind of tell a story
about how you do that and show that off
a little bit so what we're looking at
here is an environment yeah Mel file so
this is one of the ways in which you can
specify a conda environment so that
anaconda distribution that most of you
in this room have installed on your
laptop the thing that makes that
possible is the Conda packaging
framework the Conda packaging framework
is a mechanism that is a platform
independent and language independent
packaging mechanism in fact it's just
like a generic packaging mechanism so
rpms are just for Red Hat based Linux
and just first stalling mostly like
operating system level things and hip
setup tools is for Python even with
wheels with compiled binaries it's like
all Python ecosystems and NPM is just
for node and so on and so forth right
Conda is not platform specific and it's
not language specific you could put just
like data files into a kind of package
you could put like a jupiter notebook in
there you could put source code or
compiled binaries to a individual
package can be for a particular language
or for a particular platform the
packaging format itself is very generic
and that makes it very powerful
additionally the way kondeh packages are
built they're designed for supporting
generic binary packages that have
relocatable dynamic libraries inside of
them so I'm not a computer scientist and
I only have like kind of vague
understandings of how this like compiler
stuff works and how dynamic linking
works the basic idea is that it's tough
to get your dynamic libraries to it's
tough to have like not operating system
managed dynamic libraries for a piece of
software and as a result when you
compile a piece of software on a
particular machine that particular piece
of software is like that dynamic library
is probably like a lock could
potentially be locked down to that
machine especially going through like an
auto conf kind of install our PMS they
assume they're getting installed to the
root of the system there is some degree
of relocate ability in there Khanda
packaging makes use of mechanisms that
all modern operating systems support
which is to specify specific paths for
where you fetch your dynamic libraries
okay so it's like mini like mini
tutorial in package loading but the
effect of this is is that your operating
system is already excellent at isolating
software into memory when it's executing
and in two different spaces on disk and
both the things in memory the processes
in memory and the files on disk owned by
different users like operating systems
have been really great at doing that for
40 years when do we need virtual
machines and when do we need containers
we need virtual machines and containers
when we need a root filesystem when we
need a root user when we need access to
specific dedicated ports or privileged
ports like those are scenarios in which
you need a container or a virtual
machine most of us is data scientists we
don't need a root filesystem we only
need a root filesystem because the only
way we can install a piece of software
is with yum install and so then we need
a root filesystem that's the only reason
so Khanda lets us get past these sorts
of things it allows us to sandbox stuff
it allows us to create very concise
definitions so a definition of a
environment can be this is approximately
half a kilobytes like 500 bytes and
that's like your snapshot of your
executional execution environment so I
can share this I'm going to show how
this is shared and it can be shared and
how you can even get it right now you
don't need to like snapshot your
container and have something even a
small snapshot like 500 Meg's or two
gigs or 10 gigs or something like that
anybody who started using containers or
virtual machines you end up with like a
bazillion of them you don't know what to
do with them you don't how to manage and
version them and have you shipped them
to somebody else and so on and so forth
so for most data science this is the
kind of thing which gives you a very
concise definition of your computational
environment so I'm going to point to a
few pieces here so we've got this is
like our sandbox names is our
computational sandbox name PI data SF
right that's where we are today we've
got channels this is where we pull
packages from this is another nice thing
about Conda that Conda from the outset
assumed that we were gonna have some
name spacing right like Xen of Python
name spacing is a great thing let's have
more of it right problem with things
like NPM and pi PI it's like a flat
namespace ok you can like replicate you
can kind of like mirror it and then
replace on your own but there's like a
flat global namespace here we've got a
specific set of channels where we're
going to pull packages from so the stuff
we're setting up here has a support for
our stuff things from kind of forge
plotly and my own personal channel and
then we've got a set of packages that we
want in our environment so on anaconda
4.1 with python 3.5 with our essentials
our PI 2 plotly and this one here is one
that come back to a little bit later we
also can support pip installs and we
can't support everything I wish there
were a - cran colon there isn't a - cran
colon so in fact to actually do the
thing that I'm showing here I have to do
an installation for an hour package
separately but we the point is all of
the Conda stuff it's all open source
it's all the kind of framework is open
source the Conda tools and libraries
tirely open source so people could
contribute to add capabilities to this
and we can see the pip pieces here are
giving us our MATLAB connectors so we've
got our connectors we've got MATLAB
connectors and there's one our package
that doesn't have a condom version and
I've got a it's not available in our
essentials so let's care
so here we are
Sunday morning grab a breakfast tourists
the caterers kindly cooperated and
provided us with breakfast Tauruses
outside so there might even be some more
of those the coffee break they weren't
all snatched up first thing so here
we're gonna create a breakfast tourists
in Python so the point is not to read
the code here but this is the code that
gives us X y coordinate coordinates for
a torus and I should just make sure I'm
starting fresh starting clear output ok
so we've got some code here the main
thing is down at the bottom here we've
got our X Y Zed coordinates that we
create the rest of this is some fancy
numpy stuff but now we pause for a
second and say well but which Python
which numpy which side pi it's this
little bit of code here it kind of ends
up telling us that story although I have
to admit this isn't super readable let
me change my it's hard to get like the
line wrapping and font size balance
right this is Python 3.5 and we'll
notice I'm gonna bump them to fine I'm
gonna just point we can see that pythons
coming from somewhere which is actually
inside my own home directory inside my
anaconda directory and then inside these
software sand boxes is actually like
really on the file system another really
cool thing about conda environments
these kondo-san boxes is I did a cleanup
this morning because I want to show some
of this stuff off and I realized that I
had like 80 Conda environments so
anaconda the full anaconda distribution
it's not our 25 to 35 Meg download you
get from python.org it's about 250 to
350 Meg's to download installed it's
about 800 to 900 Meg's on desk so I just
told you had like 80 of those things
does that mean I was consuming about
like half a terabyte with my no not half
a terabyte like 500 like 50 50 60 gigs
with all of those Conda environments
another great thing about what Conda
does is that Conda makes use of the fact
that this is software that isn't that
it's like effectively once it's
installed it's read-only you're not like
modifying the libraries and the packages
once they're installed so actually as a
package cache and it makes use of again
things that have existed in file systems
for a very long time we don't need to
have fancy can
a virtual machine copy-on-write stuff we
just make use of linking hard linking or
sim linking if necessary only as a
fallback will Conda actually copy the
libraries if your spanning filesystems
between where the package cache is and
where you're trying to create your Conda
environment then it'll actually have to
copy the files but for me the overlap of
those 80 different Conda environments is
80 different sandboxes a single one of
them for the full anaconda distribution
about a gigabyte for me once i've added
in a bunch of things 80 of those takes
up about 3 gigabytes because i have two
versions of Python and I've got you know
a couple of multiple versions of a bunch
of those packages but every time I could
recreate a new environment if those
packages are already there the extra
cost or just the inode links and not the
actual content of the files so very fast
to create very efficient on disk space
and it's just using your natural file
system so I'm using Python and this
isn't a this is a ends up actually being
a hard link not back to the Anaconda bin
Python but actually like the package
cache version of Python and in this case
the five three point five point two and
then we can see where we're getting
numpy from inside PI things which would
look just the same as in virtual ends
and again the differences here is that
this isn't Python specific we can put in
these kondo-san boxes we can put our R
or julia or whatever other stuff we want
in fact we can even anybody who's doing
auto con if you just do dot slash
configure - - prefix equals or - -
prefix space dollar Conda underscore
prefix and then everything is going to
get installed in - everything starts
from here and down you look there and
you're gonna see like a lib directory
and then include and the bar and Etsy
and all those other pieces right so you
just install stuff straight into there
this is really powerful this is really
powerful for data scientists okay so let
me carry on to actually like showing
some stuff off so and bumping my font
size again so here we use the matplotlib
magic which gives us inlining of our map
plot lib plots so i you used to use
mount as an engineer use matlab
extensively i used to use
now plot lib extensively but only for 2d
rendering if you're an expert at
creating 3d images in matplotlib then I
leave it as a challenge to you for how
to interpolate the XYZ data points I
tried like four different things and I
couldn't get like an interpolation over
a torus surface so you're stuck looking
at 2d rendering instead of a 3d sort
instead of a 3d surface if you're smart
enough and I'm clearly not smart enough
you can also use matplotlib to
interpolate those points over a surface
and basically get a surface that you
could render but the point is is we can
inline here we can do mount plot lib
Python here's our Python two-dimensional
torus
now there are also some great libraries
for visualization besides matplotlib one
of them is bouquet leader of bouquet
projects my colleague Brian who's in the
back corner there he gave a great
tutorial on Friday bouquets very widely
used coming up for its 1.0 release but I
thought I would in community spirit
schhwaff plotly here so plotly is
another rendering interactive
visualization rendering library that's
Python based but gives you interactive
JavaScript and plotly like bouquet has
an init notebook mode here which I'm
using and I'm able to make use of some
sci-fi features and some numpy pieces to
create a surface and then use plot Li's
I plot function to go and render a nice
3d plot in from plot Lee in line in my
notebook okay so there's the Python part
now breakfast torus and MATLAB so this
is creating a connection to MATLAB
MATLAB is not included in the Anaconda
distribution I have my own version of
MATLAB on my laptop I do some
independent work it with MATLAB but
there are things which allow us to
bridge to a MATLAB kernel from a jupiter
notebook and so that's what we've got
right here using the PI map bridge
extension and then in a very succinct
bit of code here we're able to create
our parameters for our torus do a mesh
grid over a particular range and then
apply those vectorized operations
to then create a surface surface plot
now this is a static rendering unlike
our plotly 3d rendering if I had a
graphical window pop up then I'd be able
to have something that I could spin but
if it's embedded in my notebook I'm
stuck with just a static 3d image and
finally breakfast tourists in our so
here was one where there is no external
way to do this so if you wanted to
reproduce this yourself you need to do
an install plot 3d from your art
terminal but then using the our pi2
extension and the our magic we then have
a cell here full of some R code which
does exactly the same thing same
parameters using R to create a three
dimensional surface and at this point in
the talk since were more than halfway
through hopefully you're down to half of
your breakfast torus and so there's our
so in a single notebook in a single
notebook we're able to combine our
Python MATLAB you can combine SAS and
julienne of course is people who use
Jupiter regularly know there's like over
40 language kernels that you can connect
to again the advantages so when I say
the Anaconda open data science ecosystem
right now I've been talking about things
that aren't which we like we don't own
we're not like the owners of this these
things this is the the open data science
community of the people who gather here
and even bigger than this within this
group in terms of other languages and
other other spaces the parts that we're
trying to add in are the bits that I was
spending a little more time emphasizing
earlier around the conda environments
our pieces like this ability to switch
easily between these kernels which are
different versions of libraries so sorry
different versions of software setups so
we can have here pure MATLAB kernels
where anything I write is just MATLAB
code or pure are kernels where anything
I write you have to put a magic in there
it's just like I'm just doing are some
of those pieces are easy to add an in
configure and standard setup but we also
have in this version of Jupiter I've got
a notebook extension that will in turn
will see that I've got Conda
environments well let me switch between
kernels in different Conda environments
and these all have different
customizations of the software that's
available the versions of the software
that's available the version of
are the version of Python and so on so
these these pieces are the things that
let us facilitate reproducibility and so
I'm going to I'm gonna switch here to
I've talked about Conda talk about the
Conda packages and the Conda package
Conda environments
I'm gonna cut over to a terminal here
and just show you so here in my root
environment I've got Python 2.7 but if I
do source activate PI data SF I'm now
using my Python 3.5 interpreter if I do
a Kondylis run I can actually read this
276 packages in that particular Conda
environment and if I do I'm at lab 1
where I do some my MATLAB work this one
has only 85 so I'm not again the points
not to show you the list of them but
just give you a sense that these are
very distinct software environments
switching between them is in a matter of
going to some container control panel
and spinning up quickly in a couple
seconds a new docker container it's a
matter of doing a source activate means
anybody on this says I can you Iook have
access to my regular all my regular file
system stuff in the usual way I don't
have to do any funny ex forwarding for
you know connections this sort of stuff
now actually in terms of creating them
just to show this off quickly I'm going
to demonstrate two different mechanisms
by which these environments can be
created so I could do a Conda create n
and let's say I'm going to do something
for I'm going to do a demo environment
and I'm gonna create into here I'm gonna
say what I want in here is Jupiter
because we all love Jupiter
and we're gonna need numpy and bouquet
and sci-fi and I hope I get the name for
this right I think it's a scaler
scikit-learn is the package name I might
tell me I've got it wrong in which case
I'm probably just remove it
so what happened there was I gave a
specification without version numbers
for the packages that I wanted all of
the the to actually solve that Conda
went and checked with anaconda cloud to
see what was a consistent set of package
versions plus their dependencies that
could be installed it defaults to the
latest available version and if you
don't specify a Python version it uses
whatever your root Python version is now
in order to satisfy this it's going to
need to download sixteen point three
Meg's of new software and then it's
going to go in its and that's maybe
let's say twenty twenty-five packages
there it's then going to go and install
about fifty pack 50 or 60 packages
because a bunch of those are already
available on my machine so this is then
printing packages from the cache
downloading those packages to create a
new one when this is done so this
process will take about thirty seconds
or so to complete 16 Meg's is pretty
small even on the conference Wi-Fi here
to create this package a second time
would take only about five seconds to
create a new copy of it to share this
with somebody would be a matter of
creating a list of it and you could then
just email them the list of files that
you were email a requirements text file
again requirements text files Python
domain a Conda specification could be
much broader than that in terms of the
content that's available so we see here
the linking packages stage so it's going
through and linking those 50 or 60
packages and we can then just activate
and now we're using the Python from that
particular package so that's the that's
the idea for creating Conda environments
and leveraging Conda environments now in
terms of actually being able to share
those I'm going to take a moment and
show you my account on anaconda cloud so
anaconda org /ij stokes is me and we can
see here at this high level view I've
got a bunch of published environments
including this one here which is the one
we were looking at earlier and so this
is a namespaced environment definition
which other people any of
you could create simply by doing a Conda
n create I J Stokes / PI data SF so
rather than having to create a URL with
requirements file that people have to
download this kind of facility makes it
really easy for you to share a
particular setup with your with your
colleagues and collaborators it's a
really easy efficient way to do those
yeah by default this will look -
anaconda cloud for I J Stokes is like
the qualifying namespace prefix
basically but it will then create that
environment I already have that
environment so I can't create it again
but any of you could execute that right
now and you would get exactly the same
environment that I had based on that
based on that definition
so that's environment sharing anaconda
cloud is not just a repository for
Python packages you can actually use it
to put regular PI pi packages in there
and then you are able to make use of
thank you you're able to make use of
regular pip commands to install packages
and if so the token part is if you've
got a paid account so paid accounts you
can have private packages and then you
can add tokens and then share those
tokens out there with build systems or
colleagues and the tokens gonna have
lifespans and timelines you're able to
then submit your own versions of
packages in here as an alternative
additionally our packages are supported
the same kind of way so you're able to
submit our packages into anaconda cloud
you can then access them so you can
access our versions of our packages in
the cran channel but if you submit you
submitted your owns or if I submitted my
own I would just put I J Stokes there
instead and then I'd be able to install
my versions of our packages my own
in-house internal whatever versions of
our packages NPM as well so it's a
generic platform for supporting for
supporting different packages so from
this idea of conda packages the Conda
ecosystem is part of what enables the
ANA
the larger anaconda ecosystem to be big
and exciting there is a community that
has grown up just this year called Conda
Forge continuum contributes to can't
afford we did not create or think up
Conda Forge it was independently a group
of people came together and they said we
think Conda is great and we want to have
a mechanism in order to automate the
building of Conda packages so I won't go
into the details of kata for just
actually kind of could deserve its own
hole talk for how you create a package
that ends up in Conda Forge the condo
Forge system ends up submitting their
packages into anaconda cloud so the
package is built here you end up getting
through anaconda cloud but Conda Forge
has a mechanism by which you create the
software by which you submit a PR into
their repository chain and they have
about a thousand packages available now
and what are called feedstocks I believe
the numbers about a thousand it's just
taking a little while to come up so it's
a pretty long list that you can check
and so if you want to track Conda
installing something you're in trouble
building it yourself this is a good
place to come and look to see if it's
available and if you wanted to go and
install one of these things than
installing one of these packages would
be a matter of let me see if I can find
one that I don't think I have installed
so this is zero one here I'm pretty sure
as available Forge Azur so we can see
that this is available for Windows Mac
and Linux we can see that the latest
build of this was a month ago and it was
been built for a whole bunch of
different platforms for this is roar so
I could go and I could install Conda if
I just do a Conda install - see Conda
Forge
Azure that will get me a version of that
particular package
yeah so right so well through wheels
there's ways you can get binary stuff in
there but I mean I just use Conda you
know I use Condit because it kind of
fits in the fits in and open data
science ecosystem whereas wheels and
putting the effort into building wheels
locks me into just a Python world of
Python distribution Python wheels so
here we can see we see the packages that
are the dependency packages that are
getting pulled down for this is or this
for is or ml and the very last thing
we're just about out of time the very
last thing that I'm going to show off
here so this is you see the idea again
of what gets what happens here 630
kilobytes of downloads and then they're
going to get linked into the package the
last thing I'm going to show off is if I
can find the tab so is to say just in 60
seconds some words about what continuum
does so continues it sorry to to make to
make money continuum has a number of
different avenues from which we generate
revenue we provide we've got a strong
training team David Mertz is one of the
head trainers on the training team I've
myself have run like over I think 25
weeks of training for continuum we have
engineers who are engineers in data
science who most of the time are like
coding who do training so at training is
one source we do data science consulting
and python consulting but then
additionally we've have some enterprise
oriented products or enterprise oriented
products to help you understand and
differentiate from what the Anaconda
distribution is they facilitate teams of
people working together so they help
help an organization or a group of
people coordinate their anaconda
distributions and they help they help
companies be able to manage their open
data science infrastructure the people
involved the software involved and also
going from one person to a server a
couple servers to scaling out into a
cluster and how do you make use of some
of these tools so anybody could go and
build the pieces and you guys probably
can see the ways in which you could
leverage some of the stuff I've shown
you around Conda to do that well we've
done that in a particular way we've
built that and those pieces that we've
built on top of Conda we've done in a
way that's oriented towards enterprise
deployment of open data science software
and those are
for products so that's that kind of our
commercial storage so you understand
like we're good a little bit where the
line is the software is all open source
and we've got a very rich community
around a company that's very oriented
around developing and nurturing open
source technology all of our core
algorithms and code are our open source
bokade ask a number the three most
popular bouquet for interactive
visualization tasks for parallel
computing
numbah is a just-in-time compiler for
Python for two CPUs and GPUs so that's
kind of like the continuum technology we
fill in some key gaps in the open data
science space for Python but mostly you
know the 200 packages that are in the
anaconda distribution were responsible
for maybe 15 to 20 percent of them most
of them are community sourced
okay so I'm I'm thank you very much for
being here hearing about anaconda using
anaconda I'm going to say that people
have questions just come on up
afterwards because I know it's coffee
break right now but thanks for being
here thanks for doing my data and tell
us your stories and enjoy the rest of
your day thank you very much